what if superpowers popped up in rough  neighborhoods in the hood so to speak my  son is a rough kid why son is  essentially indestructible and super  strong  tech9 can make any weapon he can think  of  fade is basically able to walk through  walls they bicker a lot they snipe at  each other a lot there will be a lot of  familiar things for people like me to  remember the original but if you've  never heard of the blood syndicate ever  until right now you can jump in on page  one and you'll be fine mr crisscross  we're very lucky to get him is this  weird working with the characters again  when there was supposed to be a reboot  in progress i was down i was like okay i  think i learned  a lot of stuff up until this particular  point let's see what myself would look  like now all these characters it's gonna  be a really fun big exciting slam bang  action-packed thing and for some people  who never saw it they get to be  introduced  yeah this is not your regular superhero  book  [Music]